quit india quitté l'ain le 9 août 1942
le mahatma gandhi lancé le mouvement qui
allait aboutir à l'indépendance de la
colonie britannique
finalement obtenu en 1947 aujourd'hui on
commençait à bombay les cérémonies du
cinquantenaire
jérôme rooney après les indiens n'oublie
pas ce matin doublé ils sont en cortège
derrière le portrait du père de
l'indépendance indienne le mahatma
gandhi qui lança ici même cinq ans avant
l'indépendance le mouvement quit india
quitté l'inde contre le colonisateur
britannique
des milliers d'écoliers sont mobilisés
pour l'anniversaire de ce mouvement de
libération que gandhi aurait voulu
pacifique
mais comme le rappelle ces images de la
télévision indienne aux couleurs du
drapeau national
l'indépendance ne sera gagné qu au prix
de luttes sanglantes
pourtant l'avocat formé à londres apôtre
de la non-violence emprisonné plusieurs
fois finit par l'emporter
candy participe aux négociations qui
débouche sur l'indépendance de l'inde
dans la nuit du 14 au 15 août 47 le
départ du dernier vice-roi lord
mountbatten marquent l'effondrement de
l'empiré britannique depuis le drapeau
indien flotte sur cette grande nation
qui aura 50 ans la semaine prochaine
cette page de son histoire devenue
spectacle sera évoquée au cours de
nombreuses cérémonies marquant cet
anniversaire
fait divers